[Music]
we love seeing you in on the Oscar
nominations and that really cool
interstitial what we were bummed that
Wonder Woman didn't get any noms how did
you feeling what do you say to fans I
was very moved and touched by the
feedback of all the people that were
disappointed that Wonder Woman wasn't
nominated but we certainly never did the
movie in for that and I think that you
know you can't have it all we've done
this movie and it was received in such
an amazing wonderful way and we want to
keep this we want to stay humble and
grateful
gal gadot twas all class per usual when
et spoke with her at Revlon's live
boldly campaign launch event in New York
City on Wednesday the brunette beauty
was radiant in a plunging black gown
with metal detailing and a sheer skirt
and we just enjoy it not only as Gelles
career on fire she's got a lot to
celebrate at home to the actress and her
hubby gerund var Sano are coming up on
their 10th wedding anniversary and their
parents two two little girls are you
thinking about expanding the family any
further is that a baby you can
understand jets from the previous from
the baby you could do the Wonder Woman
sequel with that but my mom will be very
happy another question
[Music]